in 2005 psychonauts managed to make a
comically lopsided world feel
impressively realized and believable now
16 years later psychonauts 2 picks up
right where it left off and does more
than just feel the shoes of its beloved
corky predecessor but sets itself apart
as a classic in its own right
[Music]
the story picks up only days after the
first game and moments after the vr
sequel interlude psychonauts and the
rhombus of ruin 10 year old psychic
prodigy raspute naquato has saved the
leader of the psychonauts from the grips
of a maniacal dentist amateur brain
surgeon dr loboto was that you screaming
on me in an effort to discover who hired
dr lobato in the first place raz and the
other psychonaut agents enter lubato's
mind only to uncover that a far more
menacing antagonist has been pulling
lobato strings and maligula a past enemy
of the
psychonauts caligula
she's been dead for 20 years
the return of maligula tears open some
old wounds for the psychonauts leading
to a heaping load of mystery
and the suspicion of a mole within their
operation in order to unpack everything
razz must enter the minds of the psychic
six the founders of the psychonauts to
piece together a dark and hidden truth
what unravels is an unexpected turn of
events with a story constructed and
driven by the misjudged choices of its
characters and it's a heavy theme that
remains constant even through reza's own
choices early on
the rather serious narrative events are
intertwined with a spectacle of
platforming and action with each level
taking place inside of the mind of a
character
and they are dazzling displays of
creativity everything about psychonauts
2 from its environments to his history
the psychonauts themselves its enemies
and mechanics all work in tandem and
feel wholly realized it feels rich with
detail and it's all defined by its
complex cast of characters dad what are
you doing here what
well we're here to support you son
will we of course
as you bounce through minds of
characters each level's concepts in
artistic direction is reflective of the
mind in which it takes place often
putting mental conditions like addiction
ptsd and anxiety front and center in a
light-hearted manner that doesn't demean
them but rather treats them in an
approachable and empathetic way one
level in particular features depressing
themes and undertones of excessive
drinking as a design motif the level
takes place on a big open sea to sail
across with sandy islands to visit in a
beautiful clear sky overhead but the
moment i stopped to take it all in i
realized that the trees were shaped like
bottles and platforms were beer cans and
the rails i grinded on were drinking
straws suddenly the bright culprit world
i was excitedly jumping through was
instilled with a very different and
serious tone it was all nuanced balanced
with bizarre and quirky conversations
but bookended with a serious look at
someone's inner struggles with the
intent of better understanding who they
are as a person and why ah that's the
stuff
yeah a little motion really gets the
juices
flowing if you know what i mean now
while its representation of mental
conditions may be complex engaging with
the game isn't psychonauts 2 is truly a
joy to play with its action and
platforming returning from the first
game albeit much more fine-tuned and
streamlined
not that little
many abilities from the original will be
familiar to returning players
telekinesis cyblast pyrokinesis and
levitation all of which have been given
a welcome overhaul
all of these quality of life
improvements make psychonaut 2's combat
feel tight and refined
abilities can be upgraded by ranking up
which itself is done by collecting
things nuggets of wisdom figments of
imagination or side cards they can all
be found through levels and in the open
world
with the introduction of each new enemy
i was conditioned to change my playing
style forcing me to change up my
abilities in the fly taking full use of
the game's eight
burn them all abilities no matter how
good its level design is or how
imaginative its concepts get some of the
level concluding boss fights fail to
reach the same heights some are better
than others like the vomiting hand
puppets from compton's cooking level are
a standout fight
but not all of them stick the landing
more often than not fights involve a
towering enemy throwing projectiles at
you while you fend off hordes of little
baddies and the formula rarely changes
mechanically they're fine but can be
rather cliche in comparison to its
otherwise inspired levels
thankfully even after some of these
fights what then awaits is a welcome
degree of freedom and exploration
between each level i was given the
chance to explore the world tackle
levels at my own pace talk to its many
characters or do things completely out
of order exploring the hub areas which
are broken into four sections is a
distraction from the main quest but a
delightful one with no waypoints to
clutter my screen or lead me in a very
specific direction which i deeply
appreciated exploring felt organic i had
a constant curiosity to see what was
around every corner of the bustling
psychonauts hq or to climb to the top of
the trees in the woodsy questionable
area these areas all felt thoughtfully
designed and tailored to incentivize
natural exploration with identifiable
characteristics that made it a breeze to
navigate
[Music]
the world just feels really good and a
lot of that is owed to characters you
meet along the way whether it was
catching up with one of the other
interns or the lonely kind of sad
receptionist in the psycho isolation
chamber there's never a wasted line or
interaction
hello
finally i thought you'd never say hi
i tell ya i have been waiting for
someone to come visit for a long time
every interaction deep in the world and
the introduction to raz's gypsy circus
family the aquatos is the cherry on top
traveling thrill givers and
practitioners of the acrobatic arts
the game packs a lot in its 15 hour run
time but the result is something that
feels carefully considered tailored and
deliberate in everything it gave me from
the story to its gameplay to its
exploration to its music to of course
its writing
oh
is that honey peppa boy bacon i haven't
had that since my days back in
headquarters on the surface psychonauts
2 is an engaging ambitious honed in take
on colorful 3d platformers but the most
rewarding aspect hasn't just been
mastering its platforms or combat but
peeling back the layers to see what's
beneath it to take a closer look at its
characters the depth of their struggles
fears and regrets all of which serve as
the game's foundation
[Music]
it's an emotional hilarious and at times
pretty devastating story but a story
about forgiveness and second chances
it's an astonishing achievement in
nearly every regard and the
quintessential display of studio double
finds mastery and story gameplay and
distinct direction making it the
studio's best game to date
[Music]